new at noon metro police still
trying to identify what is believed to
be a 10 year old boy found
murdered near mountain springs on friday
this morning detectives gave an update
on the investigation
victoria saha is live right now from
metro headquarters with the latest
victoria
[Applause]
john we're now on to day four since that
body of that little boy was found
now over the weekend police thought that
they had a solid lead when a mother came
forward claiming it was her child
but it turned out to be a case of
misidentification since then we've
gotten
a digitally enhanced picture police are
hoping that someone knows who this boy
is hikers had found the body of the boy
friday morning
detectives believe the boy was placed
there sometime on thursday
details are still very limited right now
on how the boy died
but police did make it clear he was
murdered and the boy's death was recent
up until now they still have not been
able to positively identify the child
but today we are learning they have
gotten hundreds of tips from across the
country but their focus is nye and clark
county
metro police also says they have
followed up on every lead and tip
coming in and went door to door to see
if this boy belongs to a certain
household
they believe someone knows something
family members
people that recognize the digitally
enhanced photograph that was
pushed out over the weekend if that was
a student of theirs
call the tip line let us know that
information is a hundred percent
anonymous
and we are physically going door-to-door
looking to make sure that those children
are okay
and it could just be you know a
grandmother who
hasn't seen their grandson in several
days and you know at some point the
excuses have to stop
they say he has black hair and brown
eyes and they will continue their
investigation until they are able to
identify this boy
again this boy is believed to be
hispanic around 8 to 10 years old
weighing 123 pounds and 4
11. if you know anything you were asked
to call police
reporting live from metro headquarters
victoria saha 8 news now